[Applause]
and now we make the round number six yes
yes which I like yes all right Natalie
what is the most different aspect of
yourself do you think on this show that
might have been different than other
jobs well you know I think I get to show
all sides of Natalie Morales and there
are a lot of sides you know
there is the Latina I don't cross the
Latina side
but you know I think that's what's so
great it's a show that it's driven by
your personality by your opinions which
I have plenty of which in news you can't
necessarily do as much so and Jerry I
mean we've known each other since we
were at least teenagers I mean very
young you will never remember this we
met at a gas station on Sunset Boulevard
and you were filling up next to me and I
wasn't going to say anything and you
said hey uh you're you're an actor right
and I went yeah I'm Jerry O'Connell and
you said you were and and you said you
know you're you were a young actor
because I was in Stand By Me and I said
yeah I was I said actually Drew I I just
moved here you said hey welcome to LA
and you gave me your phone number and
you said let me know if you need
anything literally before there were
cameras or a TV show this is one of the
most giving people I mean someone who
just
I mean I
remember when you and your brother
Charlie would like come to my birthday
parties like we did become friends it
wasn't just like you know I'm not I hate
that fluffy stuff I'm like yeah yeah
like we we knew each other and hung hard
I just got to say though I just watched
this clip of you giving your wife the
beautiful Rebecca Romaine a lap dance
I am not kidding Jerry what is going on
here why are you so sexy I feel
uncomfortable because you're a married
man
[Applause]
I'm much older than I used to be Drew
hold on a second here we go
[Applause]
sorry I want to apologize I want to
apologize to the Drew HR department
Magic Mike live taught me properly there
was no touching there but was Rebecca
pleased
um
oh let me just put it this way
we have sent our kids on a sleepover
that night
as someone with a slow libido
I'm so thrilled to hear it speaking of
libido Cheryl is it true that you were a
lingerie model yes wow
he got some good producer detectives yes
yes we do by the way yes they're amazing
we don't have a video or a pictures but
like what was that experience like well
thank god there wasn't cameras and
social media back then I don't know yes
I was a lingerie model and you would
model the lingerie and then the
gentleman would purchase it and then
you'd have to give it to them but off
your body yes and I was horrible at it
so I started making them laugh and they
would go oh you're hilarious but you
don't need to do this anymore and that's
how I got deeper into comedy oh my God
yeah all right so Amanda you
thank you and you know this incredible
dad and you know your son Elvis do you
see him going into you know his father
Nick's career are you excited about that
how does that feel I mean he is just the
light of my life I love this little kid
so much and he you know he was conceived
in New Orleans born right here in New
York City not too far from your studio
and raised in Laurel Canyon I mean he
has music in his bones I mean like this
kid he loves to play the drums he loves
to sing he loves the guitar and I mean I
just kind of feel like I just want to
love him and support him whatever he
wants to do in life you know what I mean
it's all we can do is just to be there
to support and and help them on their
Journey whatever it is I don't look at
him at the piano playing just his like
innate love for it you know I would just
love for music and I love music and of
course my late husband loved music so I
just I love that it's in our house every
day that he plays it that he's singing
it and that I you know we just it bonds
us together and it's it's beautiful I
mean you know when you're a mom and you
see your kid happy it's the best thing
in the entire world it's all it's all
that matters
and Akbar speaking of family is it true
that you do some competitions with your
family and they sound really fun like
inspired fun like we all need to put it
into applications yeah you know I mean
I'm a competitive person I grew up with
six brothers uh one sister
um and you know it's it's a very
competitive household um and then played
Sports and then of course you know
hosting American Ninja Warrior along
with doing the talk and I just want to
create an environment where my kids can
a be competitive but also have fun so
um and that's something I wanted to show
all my social media but you know this
came really through the the pandemic
especially this was heightened during
the pandemic it's like man how do I keep
these kids entertained you know and then
it just started to grow I love it yeah
my kids love it there was something like
about Oreos like Landing in like hot
sauce or this yeah I got the barbecue
sauce that's not a fun combination
Oreos and barbecue sauce just don't go
but surprisingly Oreos and mustard is
not it yeah because we did it mine
landed on it the mustard is
peeling
[Applause]
what pizza salad is okay Pizza salad is
this
it's everything on the top of the pizza
on top of a salad get all the toppings
and the cheese and then lay it on top of
a bed of crunchy Iceberg yes and you
guys did it on your show I was like
that's right
[Applause]
because we all love pizza in terms of
inventions I mean literally it goes like
light bulb Pizza salad right there
[Applause]
[Music]